[Music]
okay guys I'm gonna show you a photo and
you tell me if you see anything wrong
with it oh my god they look like they're
hanging from a tree that's [ __ ]
horrible yeah and then this one looks
like this is like like like old-school
like black made during the lynching
that's what it looks like you guys are
so racist I don't even see that [ __ ] I
saw gingerbread people on a Christmas
tree she said what's wrong with it so
I'm looking for the negative first I saw
pepper and getting hanged and then yes
ran yeah cuz she's just like some
cartoon chick I think she's just like
old school made like from gone with the
wind where they're like yeah like black
you know and it's Michelle Obama to the
left that does a black chick in a kimono
so what else that was a Christmas tree
during Black History Month or one of the
guys ages Alba no that's Obama yeah yeah
it's prominent black figures it is and
you are correct it's like a Christmas
tree type for Black History Month they
were baby but you are both you guys are
also correct it looks like if the
lynching seen by the net Oh God hang
them by the way we're by the head yeah
little thing but whenever you hang
figurines though you typically do it by
the neck one side by the way yeah nah
nah how do you know that [ __ ] because
they're not bungee jumping well cuz we
have so we have a Rudolph on a Christmas
tree it's not on the neck no it's just
like a yeah
yeah but the neck is the leash for
Rudolph but it's still hot on the neck
it's on the head on the saddle or
something look at this
so Michigan State University had this
display in their gift shop and so one of
the black students there they saw this
and they're like what the [ __ ] so
apparently there are under 7% of under 7
percent of the student body is black so
have a lot of black students there you
don't have to be black to see how stupid
that [ __ ] was angry but your initial
reaction was no you know like I guess I
saw the hanging but if I'm walking
through a gift shop what I noticed that
immediately I'm not because like we're
told this is a different kind of is like
hey look at this right now what's wrong
with this picture
yeah definitely if I walk by a gift shop
the first thing I'm thinking is oh
that's just ugly cuz they weren't well
made is what you're saying it looks like
a piece of [ __ ] arts and crafts [ __ ] got
a fifth grader made look at trees a
construction paper tree think that
difference but also is like okay this
for Black History Month why they hang on
a Christmas tree you know I'm saying
like it's a lot of weird shape going on
here's another one that they also had
and yes there are white prominent
figures - that looks more like a tree I
will say that looks better so when this
black student initially saw these
figurines on the tree she asked them the
people working there like do you see
anything wrong with this and they
answered no like what are you talking
about so feel like I guess the trees not
really tree killer
that's true it's not green yeah so then
she ended up checking in with her
friends to make sure she wasn't being
hypersensitive and she said that it
ended up enraging her friends too so she
shared the images on Facebook and she
captioned it she said at the Wharton
Center gift shop they are hanging
prominent black figures from trees
hashtag MSU what a way to honor black
history why don't they just talked to
the manager like hey this might be a I
don't have II didn't see this see what I
see but this kind of insensitive way of
doing it it sounds like she did though
she talked to the management well dated
sounds like yeah she did yeah she did
ask them like
is there anything wrong with this
they're like nope it's cool oh yeah so
that's a funny reaction to instead of
saying like why what do you see
yeah we're right no it's perfectly fine
nope
anyways I gotta hey more black people on
the field the day after she posted these
photos that's when the gift shop removed
the display and then the university
apologized in a statement and you know
the way this a man how it's gonna go I
don't you know what's funny is that they
they're actually trying to celebrate
Black History right and it backfires
because they hung all their prominent
figures from trees it's so [ __ ]
stupid it's like you you feel like a lot
of this [ __ ] is like like a hyper walk
sometimes you're like oh man this is
like they're reaching but this one it's
like okay I can't get it again yeah I
get it it's pretty good all right the
stupidity is pretty funny yeah it to do
that or not nothing registers that why
it might be weird yeah oh there have
been at least five hate incidents
reported on the campuses just in one
week where's the Michigan State
University Michigan yeah so in October
there was this black student at the
University that reported that someone
tied toilet paper in the shape of a
noose on her dorm room door oh my gosh
and then so the university officials
were saying oh it's just an innocent
innocent prank it's not that big of a
deal but then she's saleable she said
that the students a crime that hers was
the only door with that decoration and
then that same month a Michigan State
professors ended up sending students a
survey that used racial slurs he said
that it was an experiment to study
students reactions to the offensive
words but then later apologized after
students complained
that's a funny experiment the
university's black students alliance
protested that month and demanded that
the university require cultural racial
and religious sensitivity training for
all university faculty and staff as well
as a mandatory class on race ethnicity
how you react when I write
and in this pamphlet I know I kind of
know which words I wish I knew it's it's
weird when like so this is Michigan yeah
mm-hmm and like you but what cities you
probably like because you know Detroit's
like super diverse right colleges are
pretty diverse - so even in like here's
the thing about like New York one of the
most diverse cities in the world right
but if you go to upstate New York does
[ __ ] gets pretty racist up there it's
crazy like what's what's considered
upstate like just Buffalo Albany Albany
ish I did a show at some school out
there one time and you know I did like
it was like an Asian hip-hop you man
right I did my little set and I'm like
I'm in New York you know I'm saying this
shit's like shit's diverse a lot of
different people out here the melting
pot I'm walking back like it was a
couple of the girls from the club that
brought me out there just like walking
me back to so where I was staying and
then this is group of drunk like frat
dude it's like white guys they they saw
our group they're walking it and one
guy's like hey guys the Great Wall is
that way and I was like what looks like
out of nowhere I got a good bit not a
good not even a good bit I was like [ __ ]
and you know I'd say I want to laugh you
know that's the thing cuz it's just so
out of the blue like what though what
would you learn you come on so [ __ ]
lame in racist I think that and also
just caught me off guard there's just
this is so ridiculous like weird even
come up with that yeah yeah I'm drunk as
[ __ ] wait wait wait wait wait try these
people hey you might be lost the great
walls that way I was pissing myself that
I didn't have a comeback you know right
there too because I was like I just was
so completely off-guard by that [ __ ] you
know what do you say to that you say
thank you for being so helpful yeah like
yeah I think they can see it from space
I think I know where I'm going yeah
stupid you like I heard your sisters
telling you come back home [ __ ] yeah
something like that looks pretty good
always works
yeah so did you end up thinking about
that for a few days Oh stay with you
Julie oh well I wish I woulda said this
yeah I mean you know you get back to I
get back to the room like [ __ ] I should
said so but it's hard to shirt your
that's not even on your mind or just
walking and just getting hit with
something no that happened me I was at a
university
[ __ ] 10 years ago doing a video yeah
and somebody's like hey man you look
like a future president to me and I was
like you know it stick with you for a
long time yeah I thought of all kinds
responses I couldn't feel my [ __ ]
casserole leader no no me I love other
[ __ ] I won't be the leader of any won't
even say this how do you feel about it
now I don't think I'll like these high
expectations me alone it's tough to do
that to somebody
I agree I'm sorry you had to go through
that thank you I saw that there's this
show on Disney about like the diary of a
future president or something
I haven't clicked on I haven't seen it
but that makes me wonder like yeah like
you know the people we know today
especially since I have a kid that I'm
like I wonder who his friends are gonna
grow like one of us could be president
or maybe not us no one of us Simmi you
could be President how many [ __ ]
prizes I wouldn't vote for Joe I think
he's got some inclinations that are
scary yeah but I vote for me thanks the
only vote that matters
you want to be President I do not wanna
be okay please believe me about them
please run for president I mean you
don't want to be President come on
please Steve please honestly think you
have a higher chance than I do I think
so could you talk about nasty [ __ ] but
people actually like you yeah he's
talking about dictatorship I think maybe
a little too buddy I'm telling you
everyone's gonna agree with me yeah how
good dictator will actually make the
world a better place a good one
you could be my running mate I want to
be vice president [ __ ] that [ __ ]
okay cool fine what's your platform to
me um they're pretty thick I only wear
them when she wears her heels yeah well
you got a campaign on eating the booty
Harry everybody boo
down for that I'll be the BPP but I'll
help ya um longer recesses that's
homework cheap more home less homework
cheaper sodas tampon machines for the
girls in the great not know the good
[ __ ] [ __ ] pearl
there we go you know what's up and you
get a point Bart you're surgeongeneral
because he because he knows all about
the surgeon general's warning with arms
wide open
[Music]